everyone Intel recently reached out to
me and asked if I would be willing to
try out their Dell XPS 15 laptop and
absolutely yes was my answer because
I've heard great things about this
computer and also because I've never
owned a PC before so let's dive in and
talk about it
[Music]
so let's talk about specs really quickly
this has got an Intel i7 processor it's
a 13th generation it's got 16 gigs of
RAM it's got 500 gigs of storage it's
got the arc graphics system and it has a
huge display that I am super impressed
with so let's dive in and check out the
unboxing Now intel made really sure to
secure this laptop for shipping the
shipping box is strong it's sturdy
there's plenty of shipping tape to keep
everything closed up I wasn't worried
about damage I also like that I can pull
these two side handles to slide the Box
up and out it's also worth mentioning
that they took the time to wrap the
computer box in this protective film and
that's a nice touch now once I flip open
the top of the box it presents the XPS
15 very well included in the box is a
charging cable a power block and this
accessory block which is really cool
it's a Thunderbolt to HDMI and USB
adapter it's a nice touch to include
that with the computer now back to the
laptop it is wrapped in a plastic wrap
to protect it within in the Box again
nice protection not worried about my PC
being scratched there's been a lot of
care put into this packaging to ensure
that the laptop is protected now here is
laptop you can see it's got a nice
profile it's a little reflective there
but uh nice logo on the top nice
aluminum exterior as well the weight is
not bad at all it's it's very manageable
for me it's not heavy very portable we
also have lots of great ports on this
computer we've got a thunderbolt porch
we've got USB ports we've got SD ports
headphone Jacks awesome sound as well
coming from the speakers on the side of
this thing on First Impressions this
thing feels super premium the initial
setup process with Windows 11 was super
easy super quick the screen quality
immediately impressed me with how
crystal clear it was as a motion
designer having a big screen edge to
edge display is awesome and I really
appreciate this display so I've had a
little bit of time to play around with
the laptop and this being my first PC it
did take me a while to kind of
understand how to navigate the interface
but once I did I downloaded Adobe After
Effects installed it seamless process
the installer went smoothly launched
After Effects even though this has got
16 gigs of ram in it which is a minimum
requirement for After Effects it ran
super smooth overall smooth playback as
well now in terms of my general
impression of this laptop again it's
super premium in my opinion the display
I can't say enough about it I absolutely
love it the battery life has been
awesome as well one thing I've noticed
is that the laptop is not loud it's not
hot which is a big thing again when
using After Effects a lot of times it
gets you know super like I hear a lot of
fans going it gets extremely warm that
is not the case with this laptop I also
got a chance to check out the webcam
when doing a zoom call and it looked
great super happy with it the mic
quality was great the speakers sounded
great overall super awesome Impressions
and I also have to mention setting up
the face recognition and the fingerprint
recognition were a breeze no problems
there and I love that I can just open up
my laptop and it immediately recognize
my face unlocks it I'm in these are
little things where they make a big
difference in the overall experience
when using a laptop it's got an amazing
display it's got good graphics good CPU
good RAM storage reasonable price would
I recommend this PC absolutely as always
thanks for watching my name is Cameron
with motion science and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
foreign